Oh what are you still doing you YouTube nubbs.
those sons of bitches they took all my
money but they demonetized all my videos.
as you can see by this background I'm
living in in the,
I'm living in the slums I'm eating,
Edgar's dog food that's right I I made
some bad investments okay I did I I
thought it was going to work out who
knew rats could it live underneath water
okay maybe I maybe I should have seen
that one coming
god dammit why do I invest all my money
in the rat under water rats nah leprosy
I have leprosy now I'm gonna have to get
a new job don't you understand the
serious and see of the situation why
aren't you looking at me huh well no I
have not something that moment I'm gonna
have to find another job what job am i
qualified what talents do I have as a
youtuber as a joke because youtubers
doesn't have talent Photoshop Photoshop
that's right
Aynsley Photoshop let's see on Twitter
what people want made a rotor shop daddy
oh five as a happy wholesome American
family now that's just straight-up
impossible
don't be ridiculous Danville cinnamon
toast can the future of YouTube right
there zooming on the nipple
the real future of YouTube you just go
to the trending tab and look whatever
cancer is on that shit
we got Roman Atwood Vox iJustine and
what's up mom's Photoshop Wall Street
Journal into a good publication okay
that should be easy enough I accept your
challenge
all right we have the Wall Street
Journal logo here and let's let's make
some fine-tuning adjustments change the
letters a little bit we rearranged
essentially just rearrange what we're
looking at here oh wow it's it's
starting to look like something could it
be a good publication my god let's add
some coloring beautiful
Dolan that will be fede bucks okay you
can PayPal me who's chaos says fuck me
up well this has already been
photoshopped okay you clearly use some
fucking filter to smooth out his skin
what are you fucking I what can we do
with this I don't fucking know I'm going
to be honest here you look like shit I'm
sorry you don't look great but
there-there is the solution okay I have
a problem with the fact that you're
trying to steal my hair and but I will
say you have a huge fucking nose and
that you know represent as a fellow
member of the big-ass nose community I
appreciate you and I want to accentuate
your best features why I can't submit by
just lifting them up just a tiny bit we
don't want you to look weird or bad or
anything so let's just do that
so let's describe that beautiful nose
and let's get rid of you wow that is
look Wow
can you tell I'm good at Photoshop oh my
god it looks so real
can't you tell by the pixels yep I'm
definitely not regretting spending time
on this one I definitely think this was
worth the effort make him happy
who cries on camera what a goddamn loser
I can't allow that to happen I will do
it for free this should be easy
oh fuck I fucked it up I fucked it up
goddamnit I'm not cut out for this
that's not just mean G make me into a
dodge please notice me senpai it's my
dream to be in one of your vids well
your wish is my command as long as you
pay pal I have a feeling she's gonna
regret this I just found the perfect
dodge the perfect I mean already I can't
tell the difference alright let's start
with the eyes make it make it nice and
simple to be honest already you look ten
times better Felix the plastic surgeon
here to fulfill all your needs moving on
to the note that looks great
I love my lime thank you for asking yes
I think we're getting somewhere next
time it'd be really great if you could
send me in like a little lower rest
photo that would be really helpful thank
you it looks like we're gonna have to
give you a complete new set of teeth yes
yes now just the ears I don't see your
ear so I'm just gonna have to guess
actually never mind there's a little ear
tip that's all we got to work with
that's all we were doing yeah yes proper
dog ears wow look at that
and you're really wearing a necklace so
there there you go Oh oh my god Jesus
Christ
let's have a little look-see before
after my god you look great honey
not only 50 bucks thank you oh my god if
this continues I might be able to
support myself make me into a helicopter
you know what I feel privileged to help
you in your transition into an Apache
helicopter you're so brave let's take
your sorry don't mean to be rude but you
have weird ass fingers disgusting but
they will make you fly fucking like did
you have to cover up your whole goddamn
face Wow
so brave okay what a grace is it yeah
fucking dumb oh my god okay ah
another satisfied customer
Wow it feels great that I can make
people feel good can you give me big
muscular arms a poor soul in pain in
need he doesn't have any arms it will be
my honor my privilege and my duty you
know some people say that using
Photoshop generated arms is unethical
dangerous can cause life's
life-threatening disease no I say no
there's nothing wrong with it there's
nothing wrong with having arms and if
you have a problem with having arms
you've got a problem with me because I
have arms what the fuck am I talking
about dude you're gonna look so small we
need to work out when you look this good
when you look this good boy damn dog you
go fuck them hoes up hit man you look
fucking at a touch
holy shit damn you look amazing another
satisfied customer thank you give
Gerrard his eyebrows back what happened
to Gerard's eyebrows you know what not
Mike not none of my business
not a my Beza I've always wondered I
know you think you've thought the same
thing I've always wondered what would it
be like to have ok meseta let's say it
on three one two caterpillar eyebrows
yes on point how high five
caterpillar eyebrows is the new hippest
trend that a lot of people don't know
about I was a fan of caterpillar before
caterpillars were cool okay alright
alright
caterpillars it's my thing it's what I
define my identity around
peddlers I've been thinking about this
caterpillar thing for a long time
and I want you to know Gerard if you
actually want me to hit you up with some
caterpillar eyebrows I can give you a
discount just because I really like your
music would you like some candy Peter a
bee we came down there and come now you
get to caterpillar for free you get one
caterpillar is a friend that's Frank you
get to print a caterpillar free while
hillocks it looks good
it looks really good it feels rewarding
it's Edgar's turn to be in the middle
thank you so cute
Jesus guys chill it was pretty pie come
on Wallace read you want fortify I swear
I can tell you everything about the fuck
fix this okay no problem
you're welcome
you're welcome that'll be another 50
here's a classic example of how the fuck
am I supposed to do that turn me into
this pug okay well you're covering your
whole guy do you have glasses and a
fucking mug in your face how am I
supposed to do that now just because you
made such a dumb suggestion I'm going to
turn this cup into the pod look what an
amazing time that part of that mug has
what the fuck am i doing
god dammit the fucking on monetization
man I don't know what to do I don't know
what to do but now I know thanks to you
guys and my amazing talent we can work
this out together
appreciate you and as always a little
high came in without one